que vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs les projets
de loi de règlement 2021 et 2022 dont
nous entamons l'examen ont vous le savez
sans doute été rejeté début juin par
l'Assemblée nationale ceci ont également
fait l'objet d'un double rejet par la
commission des finances du Sénat la
semaine dernière c'est une majorité se
dégage aujourd'hui pour rejeter ses
textes soit par le vote d'une question
préalable soit par un vote négatif à
l'issue de leur examen nous laisserions
notre pays pour deux années de
consécutives sans loi d'approbation des
comptes de l'État parce que c'est bien
de cela qu'il s'agit pas d'inquiétus
donné au gouvernement mais de textes qui
ne font que traduire une exécution
budgétaire
est-ce que ce rejet probable si j'en
comprends les premiers échanges en
commission mais en péril nos finances
publiques il faut être honnête la
réponse est non est-ce que cela nous
empêchera de présenter et de faire voter
je l'espère la loi de finance de l'année
prochaine non plus la réalité c'est que
les conséquences immédiates sont avant
tout de nature comptables que s'est-il
passé l'année dernière suite au rejet du
projet de loi de règlement de l'année
2021 la première conséquence c'est que
très logiquement le bilan et le compte
de résultat de l'exercice n'ont pas été
approuvé ce qui n'a d'ailleurs pas
empêché la Cour des comptes de les
certifier pour autant je suis incapable
de dire comment la cour après andra la
situation si année après année les lois
de règlement sont systématiquement
rejetées par le Parlement ensuite du
point de vue de la comptabilité générale
le solde des opérations de l'exercice
2021 n'a pas pu être affecté au report à
nouveau enfin du point de vue de la
comptabilité budgétaire il n'a pas pu
être procédé au non-report du sol de
comptable de certains comptes spéciaux
mais le plus important ce ne sont pas
les cons comptable même si les rejets
successifs nous font entrer en terre
inconnue le plus important c'est ce que
cela dit je crois de notre débat
politique je l'ai déjà dit et je le
répète aujourd'hui devant vous je ne
comprends pas la position qui consiste à
rejeter un texte qui ne fait que rendre
compte simplement de l'exécution
budgétaire j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire je fais partie des quelques membres
du gouvernement qui sont également élus
locaux je suis conseiller municipal
depuis près d'une dizaine d'années dans
ma commune je siège dans l'opposition
dans ma commune j'ai régulièrement voté
contre des budgets présentés par
l'exécutif municipal dans ma commune je
ne vote pas contre le compte
administratif qui est présenté au
printemps au début de l'été c'était le
cas dans mon conseil municipal il y a
quelques jours en quelques semaines j'ai
voté pour le compte administratif alors
même que je n'avais pas voté pour le
budget simplement parce que le compte
administratif administratif de la
commune ne fait que rendre compte de ce
qui s'est passé l'année précédente il en
va de même pour le projet de loi de
règlement qui est ici présenté
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec la
politique qui est menée bien sûr nous
avons des désaccords sur les choix
économiques financiers et fiscaux mais
c'est des accords nous avons loisir de
les exprimer lorsque nous débattons du
projet de voiture finance et lorsque
nous débattrons du projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 je crois que nous nous
trompons d'exercices je ne dis pas que
ces lois devrait être l'occasion de nous
rassembler sur le fond je dis simplement
qu'elle ne devrait pas constituer un
prétexte pour nous diviser à nouveau
alors même encore une fois qu'on peut
être en désaccord avec la politique qui
a été menée l'an passé qu'on peut
regretter des chiffres de sol de public
de croissance qui ont été réalisées l'an
passé mais on ne peut pas les changer
on peut pas changer le passé on peut
tirer des conséquences des conclusions
de ce qui s'est passé dans le passé pour
des choix à l'avenir mais on peut
imaginer voter un amendement rejeter un
projet de loi de règlement ça ne
changera rien à ce qu'il s'est passé
l'année dernière puisque ce texte ne
fait que traduire l'exécution comptable
et donc de la même manière que dans les
conseils municipaux et je suis sûr que
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs vous êtes évidemment
régulièrement en lien avec des maires
avec des conseillers municipaux avec des
élus locaux eux-mêmes vous le disent ça
n'a pas de sens de voter contre un
compte administratif et de chercher à le
rejeter puisqu'il ne fait que traduire
l'exécution budgétaire de la même
manière je le redis ici je ne comprends
pas la position qui consiste à rejeter
de manière systématique pavlovienne des
projets de loi de règlement qui ne sont
que la traduction une photographie de
l'exécution des comptes de l'année
passée voilà le regret que je me permets
d'exprimer devant vous aujourd'hui même
si je sais que je ne réussirai pas
probablement pas à vous convaincre mais
j'essaye quand même
à nouveau par le vote probable de tout à
l'heure le Parlement rejetterait une loi
d'approbation des contes faits inédit
depuis la Monarchie de Juillet nous
aurons d'ailleurs exactement le même
débat tout à l'heure s'agissant de la
loi d'approbation des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale qui vraisemblablement
subira le même sort d'autant plus
regrettable d'ailleurs que cette
nouvelle catégorie de loi consacrée au
niveau organique en 2021 était la
première du genre et a pour objet
d'informer davantage le Parlement et de
nous permettre d'avoir un débat mais
encore une fois pas de changer le passé
puisque on n'a pas encore trouvé la
DeLorean qui nous permet de revenir dans
le passé pour le changer comme dans le
film bien connu ce point préalable est
en fait permettez-moi de revenir
rapidement sur l'exécution budgétaire de
l'année 2021 vous le savez 2021 a été
une année de bascule où nous sommes
passés presque sans transition de la
crise covid à celle de l'inflation dans
ce contexte nous avons agi pour protéger
les Français tout en enclenchant le
redressement de nos comptes le déficit
public a été ramené à 6,5% du PIB contre
8,9 en 2020 et la dette publique à
112,5% soit 2 points de moins que
l'année précédente donc 2021 a marqué la
première année d'une dynamique vertueuse
pour nos finances publiques poursuivi en
2022 et dont nous ne dévirons pas non
nous n'en dévirons pas parce que c'est
une question de souveraineté d'autonomie
de capacité à protéger nos compatriotes
face aux menaces et face aux crises le
projet de loi de règlement en 2021
présenté aujourd'hui a fait l'objet par
rapport à la version de l'année dernière
d'une actualisation il s'agit simplement
d'une modification de l'article
liminaire que le gouvernement propose
par amendement pour mettre à jour les
chiffres de la croissance pour 2020 et
2021 suite à la publication des comptes
nationaux de l'Insee publié le 31 mai
dernier là aussi on peut rien y changer
ça n'est que la publication des comptes
arrêtés et du niveau de croissance
arrêté par l'INSEE au 31 mai dernier
l'évolution du PIB en volume a été revu
à moins 7,5% en 2020 trit de covid
contre -7,8% auparavant
et plus 6,4% en 2021 contre + 6,8%
auparavant j'en profite pour dire que
nous avons également actualisé l'article
liminaire du projet de loi de règlement
2022 pour tenir compte de cette
publication de l'Insee qui revoit la
croissance de l'année dernière à plus
2,5 % contre plus 2,6% précédemment
comme à l'Assemblée nationale
l'amendement déposé par le Gouvernement
permet de modifier la décomposition du
sol de public entre composants
structurels et conjoncturel tout en
laissant inchangé le déficit public qui
s'établit à 4,7% l'année dernière
je reviens maintenant aux principaux
enseignements de l'exécution budgétaire
de l'année dernière le premier
enseignement à tirer c'est que notre
action résolue contre la hausse des prix
a produit des résultats même si je sais
que la situation reste difficile pour
des millions de nos compatriotes
pourquoi a-t-elle produit des résultats
parce qu'on s'attaquant au prix de
l'énergie avec les boucliers gaz
électricité nous avons cassé la spirale
inflationniste et préserver la
croissance économique c'était je crois
le bon choix parce qu'en préservant la
croissance nous avons créé les
conditions pour que les recettes restent
dynamiques et c'est précisément le
dynamisme des recettes qui explique
l'amélioration de notre déficit public
l'année dernière il est passé de 6,5% en
2021 je le disais à 4,7% l'année
dernière je vous donne un chiffre au
global les recettes ont progressé de
7,3% en 2022 après avoir progressé de
8,4% en 2021
cette croissance des recettes repose
principalement sur la progression de
l'impôt sur les sociétés plus 15,8
milliards ce qui nous a permis
d'atteindre un record d'impôt sur les
sociétés avec 62,1 milliard d'euros
prélevé l'année dernière alors même je
le redis que le taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés a été ramené à 25% au lieu de
33 %. je vais aussi relever la hausse
des recettes d'impôts sur le revenu plus
10,3 milliards d'euros notamment grâce
au dynamisme du prélèvement à la source
et du prélèvement forfaitaire unique et
de la TVA plus 5,3 milliards comme
pendant la crise covid nous avons fait
le choix de la protection des Français
face à la vie chère tout en poursuivant
le redressement de nos finances
publiques ce contexte de crise dans
lequel nous avons évolué tout au long de
l'année 2022 explique pour une large
part le niveau de report de crédit en
effet l'année dernière a été marquée par
l'extinction de la majorité des mesures
de soutien sanitaire et aussi par la
forte montée en charge des mesures de
soutien énergie initiés dès l'automne
2021 ainsi que par les conséquences de
la guerre en Ukraine sur le budget des
armées
ainsi de nombreux dispositifs de soutien
ont fait l'objet de crédit en loi de
finance rectificative première à l'été
et en deuxième loi de finance
rectificative de fin de gestion pour
l'hiver 2022 2023 et ont donc connu des
montants importants de report je pense
au chèque exceptionnel à destination des
ménages aux aides ciblés aux entreprises
notamment les reports de 2022 vers 2023
s'il reste à des niveaux élevés à 18,8
milliards d'euros pour suivre leur
réduction puisqu'ils étaient de 23,2
milliards d'euros l'an passé et 36,7
milliards il y a 2 ans notre objectif
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire et de
revenir à des niveaux proches de ceux
que nous avons connu pré-crise c'est à
dire autour de 3 milliards d'euros par
an
le deuxième enseignement que je tire de
l'exécution de l'année dernière c'est
que le solde des administrations
publiques demeurent très dégradés
précisément parce que nous avons
consacré des moyens considérables pour
chercher à casser la spirale
inflationniste au total pour les années
2021 et 2022 nous avons mis 34,5
milliards d'euros net en comptant donc
les recettes de CSPE et de cris sur la
table pour lutter contre l'inflation au
travers des boucliers énergétiques le
montant est considérable mais la vérité
c'est que le coût des boucliers ce sera
toujours moins cher que les deux points
d'inflation que nous aurions en plus qui
nous les avions pas mises en place donc
c'est un choix que nous assumons oui la
situation de compte demeure préoccupante
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons impérativement tenir nos
objectifs de finance publique et
accélérer le désendettement de la France
à horizon 2027 je vous rappelle les
objectifs qui sont les nôtres à horizon
2027 un déficit public ramené à 2,7%,
une dette réduite de 4 points de PIB
pour atteindre ces objectifs nous avons
une méthode désormais éprouvée c'est de
en revue des dépenses publiques nous
ferons des économies grâce à elle
d'abord nous voulons responsabiliser les
acteurs en matière de dépenses de santé
ensuite il y a deux politiques publiques
sur lesquelles nous allons agir dans le
logement et l'emploi enfin le dernier
axe c'est la chasse aux niches fiscales
qui porte sur les énergies brunes on ne
peut pas vouloir accélérer la transition
énergétique écologique et dans le même
temps continuer à encourager fiscalement
les dépenses et les énergies les plus
polluantes notre stratégie ce n'est pas
l'austérité c'est tout simplement la
responsabilité et le projet de loi de
finances 2024 le traduire et je le dis
clairement nous avons besoin de tout le
monde pour réussir et l'État ne pourra
pas être le seul évidemment dans cette
logique et il n'est d'ailleurs d'ores et
déjà pas le seul mais la première chose
que je veux rappeler c'est qu'il n'y
aura pas de mécanisme de contrainte pour
les collectivités territoriales la
première ministre s'y était engagée et
ne reviendrons pas dessus nous voulons
la confiance pas la contrainte en
revanche ce que nous prévoyons dans ce
projet de loi de programmation pour les
collectivités c'est une évolution un
objectif d'évolution de la dépense de
fonctionnement de moins 0,5 point par
rapport à l'inflation je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le dernier programme de
stabilité a acté un durcissement de
l'objectif sur l'état qui passe de -04
en volume à -08% tandis que celui pour
les collectivités reste inchangés à -05
pour 100 on passe donc d'une situation
où les collectivités étaient amenées
dans la trajectoire à faire davantage
d'efforts que l'État à une situation où
l'État fera davantage d'effort que les
collectivités locales oui nous aurons
besoin de tout le monde pour réussir de
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
mais également de tous les groupes
politiques car je pense que nous pouvons
nous retrouver assez largement autour
d'une idée simple celle qu'il faut
maîtriser ses finances pour conserver la
maîtrise de notre destin national
l'année dernière nous avons expérimenté
ensemble les dialogues de Bercy la
conclusion que j'en tire c'est qu'on
gagne toujours à discuter à échanger
cette année je voudrais démarrer
l'exercice plus en amont pour travailler
de manière plus approfondie encore et
pour essayer de construire ensemble le
meilleur budget possible pour les
Français nous allons maintenant avoir
les débats sur ces projets de pas de
règlement j'imagine bien que le
rapporteur général que les différents
représentants des groupes feront des
critiques politiques sur les
orientations budgétaires du gouvernement
et c'est parfaitement légitime en
démocratie probablement que le
rapporteur général que certains
représentants des groupes politiques
regretteront un niveau de déficit encore
trop élevé l'an dernier des niveaux de
report trop importants nous avons eu
l'occasion d'avoir des débats lors de
l'audition en commission mais ce que je
redis c'est que le fait de rejeter ce
texte ne changera rien à ce qu'il s'est
passé simplement cela rend des
opérations comptables plus compliquées
ce que j'exprimais au début de cet
échange et je crois que ça n'est pas
cohérent avec ce qui se passe dans la
quasi-totalité ou l'écrasante majorité
de nos collectivités locales ou lors de
la présentation du compte administratif
on a évidemment des votes et des débats
d'une autre nature que lorsque l'on
présente des budgets en tout cas
s'agissant des groupes politiques et des
élus constructifs je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre mais j'en
suis sûr le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances Monsieur
Jean-François Husson qui a maintenant la
parole pour 10 minutes va pouvoir vous
répondre de manière constructive
naturellement sur l'importance général
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mais chers collègues
une fois n'est pas coutume en effet
Monsieur le Ministre aujourd'hui nous
examinons deux projets de loi de
règlement du budget et d'approbation des
comptes l'un pour 2021 l'autre pour 2022
une procédure d'autant plus
extraordinaire que le premier texte est
en substance
identique à celui présenté déjà rejeté à
l'été 2022 par les deux assemblées les
conséquences du rejet l'an dernier ont
été relativement mineures puisque ce
sont surtout des procédures comptables
spécifiques qui ont dû être mises en
place dans le bilan de l'état même si un
nouveau rejet pourrait causer des
difficultés dans la gestion de certains
comptes spéciaux alors je vous épargner
une présentation bien sûr exhaustive du
texte vous m'avez déjà entendu l'an
dernier mais l'article luminaire s'il
évolue légèrement pour tenir compte des
chiffres à jour de l'Insee ce qui a
justifié le rejet du texte l'an dernier
demeure premièrement des comptes publics
de la France profondément dégradés
malgré la crise économique deuxièmement
un niveau historiquement élevé des
dépenses de l'État troisièmement et ça
fait partie de l'exécution budgétaire un
montant extraordinaire des reports de
crédit très contestables et ce vote
était cohérent vous l'avez dit avec le
vœu du Sénat sur la loi de finance
initiale la commission des finances vous
propose donc de nouveau de ne pas
adopter ce projet de loi de règlement
pour 2021 et d'ailleurs il en sera de
même pour la loi de règlement pour 2022
puisque beaucoup des critiques que nous
formulons sur l'exécution 2021 reste
pleinement d'actualité cette année d'un
point de vue macroéconomique lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
pour 2022 j'avais souligné caractère
légèrement optimiste de la prévision
gouvernementale qui anticipait une
croissance de plus 4%, il y avait des
incertitudes comme par exemple l'ampleur
de la reprise poskovit mais c'est
surtout le déclenchement convenons-en
inattendu d'ailleurs en Ukraine qui a eu
des effets à la fois majeur immédiat sur
notre économie avec des augmentations
très fortes des énergies et puis au-delà
des incertitudes géopolitiques un retour
d'une inflation élevée la croissance
c'est finalement établie à
2,5% tandis que l'inflation a accéléré
pour attendre à taux moyen annuel de
plus 5,2 % face à cela les mesures de
soutien mise en oeuvre par l'État à
hauteur de 38 milliards d'euros ont
permis d'afficher un taux d'inflation
relativement plus faible c'est vrai en
France que chez nous principaux
partenaires mais mais il y a un mais la
situation des finances publiques en 2022
et pour tout dire inquiétante et devrait
vous nous conduire à agir vite le
déficit public pour 2022 s'est élevé à
4,7% du PIB
si c'est un peu mieux que la prévision
initiale n'oublions pas que nous sommes
tout de même très éloigné des + 0,3% qui
était prévu dans la loi programmation
des finances publiques sur la période
2018-2022 et la survenue des crises
énergétiques et sanitaires je vous vois
venir monsieur Miss ne suffit
malheureusement pas à expliquer cet
écart en réalité le gouvernement votre
gouvernement a cessé de tenir ses
promesses de maîtrise et dépenses
publiques à compter des événements des
gilets jaunes
moins d'un an après le début du premier
quinquennat et d'ailleurs les dépenses
publiques ont connu un rythme de
rotation or mesure de crise plus rapide
au cours du quinquennat
2017-2022 que pendant le quinquennat
précédent monsieur le ministre je pense
que vous pouvez pas vous enorgueillir de
ce fait la hausse de près de 16
milliards d'euros de la charge des
intérêts de la dette doit tout
particulièrement nous alerter sur les
risques que nous prenons à financer nos
dépenses à crédit d'autant que les
conditions de financement de la France
ont changé en outre la légère baisse de
l'endettement public par rapport à 2021
est simplement le fruit d'une croissance
du PIB plus dynamique que celle de la
dette et parmi nous voisins nous
maintenant dit déficits parmi les plus
élevés depuis 2020 et nous présentons un
niveau d'endettement parmi les plus
importants à vrai dire pas vraiment un
motif de fierté par ailleurs l'année
était marquée par de bonnes surprises en
matière de recettes fiscale mais il
serait à mon avis imprudent de compter
sur de tels en favorables à l'avenir
d'autant qu'un ralentissement de
l'économie n'est pas exclure au second
semestre de cette année venons-en au
budget de l'État dans le déficit
s'établi en 2022 un niveau de
151,4 milliards d'euros alors le
gouvernement souligne qu'il s'agit d'une
amélioration de près de 20 milliards
d'euros par rapport à 2021 mais un
déficit aussi élevé monsieur Miss ne
peut constituer à lui seul un motif de
satisfaction d'autant que le sol ne
s'améliore que parce que les dépenses du
plan d'urgence et du plan de relance
c'était une progressivement et c'est
heureux et que de nombreux éléments dans
ce budget restent inquiétant pour
l'avenir il convient d'ailleurs de noter
que l'écart entre les recettes et les
dépenses du budget général s'élargit
dangereusement au fil des années
puisqu'il atteint désormais
55%. tout d'abord
si déficit est finalement proche de la
prévision initiale ça s'explique
malheureusement par une surestimation
des dépenses en cours d'année
parallèlement une sous-estimation des
recettes je note d'ailleurs depuis trois
ans
d'importants de prévisions en fin
d'année à une période où normalement la
plupart des recettes sont pourtant déjà
connues la Cour des comptes ne s'y est
pas trompée puisqu'elle propose de mieux
analyser ces difficultés nouvelles du
gouvernement de prévisions par ailleurs
2022 c'est l'année d'une Ford
dégradation de 19 milliards d'euros du
compte de résultat ce qui signifie que
les décisions prises en 2022 ont des
conséquences sur les dépenses futures et
engage l'avenir
un autre exemple du poids décision
récente sur les dépenses futures et le
montant des restes à pays qui ont
augmenté entre 2017 et 2022 de 87% sans
compter les 163 milliards d'euros qui
résulte de la création artificielle du
programme d'amortissement de la dette et
pourtant la dette elle-même constitue un
poids sur le futur et sa charge est
malheureusement repartie à la hausse la
hausse des recettes fiscales nette n'est
de son côté pas si spectaculaire si on
le regarde un moyen terme en
neuroconstant le niveau des recettes et
seulement comparable à celui de 2017 et
d'ailleurs sous l'effet principalement
de nombreux transferts de TVA
les recettes non fiscales augmentent
quant à elles depuis deux ans en raison
principalement déversements européens au
titre du plan de relance mais il
convient de souligner la hausse très
importante du produit de la vente des
quotas carbonées en dire un mot alors
qu'il est négligeable il y a quelques
années la hausse du cours du carbone
assuré des rentrées de 1 milliard 4
d'euros pour les temps 2022 sans compter
près de 500 millions d'euros affectés à
l'ANA cette ressource monsieur le
ministre est amené à sa croître voir à
se multiplier dans les années à venir et
de notre point de vue de mon point de
vue elle devra contribuer au financement
de la transition écologique
l'état voit ses recettes augmentées à
moyen terme alors on pourrait croire
qu'il va limiter ses dépenses en
conséquence et bien non nous nous
trompons vous tromper au contraire les
dépenses sont à la hausse 2020 des
conseillé une exception la crise de 2020
2010 pardon à la crise de 2020 a conduit
un nouveau plancher de dépenses situé
presque un quart au dessus de celui de
2019 pour 2022 je l'ai dit baisse des
missions plan de relance et surtout plan
d'urgence toutes les autres dépenses
sont en très forte augmentation
notamment dans le les mesures prises en
faveur de la lutte contre l'inflation
notons également que les effectifs sont
en baisse mais non pas du fait de d'un
choix résolu du gouvernement ou se nise
pas du tout c'est simplement parce que
il y a également une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre et pourtant la masse salariale
augmente en raison principalement du de
la revalorisation du point d'Alice
je terminerai mon intervention en
soulignant le fait que le budget exécuté
apparaît d'année en année et c'est
important de le dire de plus en plus
éloigné l'autorisation parlementaire
j'en tête bien sûr les importants report
de crédit d'une année sur l'autre mais
cette année vous avez innové puisque une
partie des crédits de 2021 ont été
reportés que pour équilibrer
artificiellement le décret du 21 avril
2022 il fallait penser mais je rappelle
que nous l'avions dénoncé dans notre
avis de même la création du d'un
programme de remboursement de la dette
covid qui brouille la notion
d'autorisation d'engagement enfin je ne
vous cache pas monsieur le ministre vous
allez voir
combien ça me choque il s'avère que
certaines mesures votées en loi de
finance rectificative ici au Sénat non
pas été exécutés correctement je pense
par exemple à la carte Vitale
biométrique pour laquelle 4 millions 3
euros seulement sur les 50 millions
d'euros ont été dépensés
alors que 50 millions d'euros avaient
également été ajoutés en loi de finance
rectificative en fin d'année pour
financer le réseau routier des
collectivités territoriales et bien ces
crédits ont été orientés en gestion sur
le financement des ouvrages d'art du
réseau routier national c'est proprement
scandaleux inacceptables les accords de
CMP doivent être respectés or nous ne
nous y reprendrez pas en conclusion je
le dis le gouvernement exploite toutes
les procédures au détriment de l'esprit
de la LOLF le budget de plus en plus
flou la loi de finances ne donc qu'une
vision imprécise de la réalité
d'exécution du budget réduisant ainsi la
portée d'autorisation parlementaire
compte tenu de l'ensemble des éléments
et sans que cela constitue à aucun
réflexe pavlovien je vous rassure
monsieur le ministre nous proposons le
rejet de ces deux textes de cet
après-midi
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
nous passons à la discussion de la
motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable sur le projet de loi de
règlement du budget et d'approbation des
comptes de l'année 2022 Monsieur
Pascal ça vole Delhi Eric Bocquet et les
membres du groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologistes ont déposés une
motion distribuée sous le numéro 1
tendante à opposer la question préalable
au projet de loi de règlement la parole
est à Monsieur Pascal ça vole d'Élie
pour la motion pour 10 minutes
sur le président monsieur le ministre et
mes chers collègues malgré un refus
argumenté par le Parlement l'année
dernière le gouvernement décide à
nouveau nous soumettre le projet loi de
règlement de l'année 2021 le même texte
par définition car ça c'est vrai vous
pouvez pas modifier le résultat en
exécution du budget de notre pays non
tact mais vous avez quand même fait vous
avez fait filles des 235 votes comptes
du Sénat des 68 abstentions exprimées
les dernières vous avez fait fier aussi
des 173 voix contre le texte exprimé en
lecture définitive engendrant son rejet
par l'Assemblée nationale et bien que la
démocratie parlementaire s'y soit
montrée défavorable vous persistez il
est donc pas surprenant que cette
proposition a été rejetée une nouvelle
fois à l'Assemblée nationale en première
lecture
monsieur le ministre comment expliquer
vous le dépôt de votre projet de loi de
règlement hors délais alors même que
c'est vous qui aviez décidé d'avancer ce
même délai lors de la révision de la loi
organique relative aux lois de finances
la Golf sur ce point le projet de loi de
règlement pour 2022 seul légitime à nous
être soumis a été déposé dans les temps
ceci dit nous retrouvons les mêmes
caractéristiques qui nous obligent par
Constance politique à réitérer nos
qualificatifs c'est un budget exécuté
appliqué de façon insincée cette notion
de rejet est chère collègue vise à
envoyer un signal puissant nous ne
pouvons plus simplement rejeter depuis 4
ans
5 sûrement à l'issue de ce débat les
projets de loi de règlement les uns
après les autres
faire comme si rien n'était
il nous faut un geste fort bien que nous
fusions opposés à ces projets de loi
notre groupe n'avait pas déposé de
telles motions
même après la crise sanitaire malgré les
dérives budgétaires inédites pourtant
alors que la situation sanitaire est
revenue à la normale l'irresponsabilité
budgétaire n'a pourtant pas cessé c'est
une question préalable d'anticipation du
prochain budget une question préalable
qui exprime un plus jamais ça en matière
de piétinement de l'autorisation
budgétaire une question préalable
d'intérêt général placée sous le saut de
la sincérité de la transparence ce que
j'appelle ce parking politique ne peut
plus durer et l'art de l'anti catasthase
doit cesser en effet les projets de loi
de finances de 2021 et 2022 tout comme
les projets loi de finances intervenus
en cours d'année agrège des prévisions
manifestement hors de propos avec la
réalité en exécution laissant ouvertes
la voix de la sincérité budgétaire
doublée je vous le dis d'une sincérité
politique je le dis et je le répète les
finances publiques sont gérés à la
petite semaine vous atteignez un déficit
public à 151,4 milliards d'euros 4,7% ce
niveau est inférieur au 6,5% de l'année
précédente soit 19,3 milliards d'euros
de moins
le temps est quasiment celui déterminé
en loi de finance initiale à 8 milliards
d'euros près ce qu'on pourrait appeler
des broutilles même si c'est quand même
le niveau des recettes annuelles que
vous prélevez sur les seuls
travailleuses et travailleurs par votre
contre-réforme des retraites et oui nous
n'aurons jamais fini d'en parler et
alors vous nous dites tout à l'heure que
ici on serait trompé d'exercice on se
trompe pas l'Assemblée nationale on se
trompe Sénat depuis des années
d'ailleurs on n'arrête pas de se tromper
mais le respect apparent de la loi de
finances initiale cache pourtant une
sous-estimation monsieur le ministre et
massive des recettes fiscales plus 27,5
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2021 +
35,7 milliards d'euros par rapport au
projet de loi de finances initiale plus
7,5 milliards par rapport au dernier
collectif budgétaire les rentrées
fiscales sont bien extrêmement
dynamiques bien supérieur à ce que vous
escomptiez là je vous pose la question
j'avoue que j'ai un début de réponse
est-ce que c'est une erreur on n'est pas
plutôt autour d'un tour de passe-passe
une forme d'aveuglement choisi voulu
face au profit aux autres dividendes
enfin vous voyez par ou même vous nous
direz l'exposé des motifs du projet de
loi de règlement est extrêmement clair
sur les raisons de ces envolésistes
c'est rentrés fiscal je cite les
recettes d'impôt sur le revenu net sont
ressaut de 6,6 milliards par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale
essentiellement lien avec le dynamisme
de la masse salariale et des dividendes
fin de citation deuxième raison c'est
l'explosion de l'impôt sur les sociétés
en augmentation de 45% par rapport à
2019 expliquant je cite que les recettes
d'impôt sur les sociétés nettes sont
supérieures de plus de 22,1 milliard par
rapport à la prévision initiale
voici la première en sincérité politique
la négation la négation de
l'augmentation des profits des
entreprises pour fin de ne pas savoir ce
qu'est un profit et un autre moment un
super profit c'est une mission coupable
dont les prévisions budgétaires n'ont
été qu'un support le front Monétaire
International a publié des éléments je
le cite la hausse des bénéfices des
entreprises a été le principal moteur de
l'inflation en Europe au cours des deux
dernières années les entreprises ayant
augmenté leur prix au-delà de la flambée
des coûts de l'énergie importée fin de
citation je m'adresse à cet instant à au
gouvernement mais aussi à mes collègues
il faut cesser de mettre le retour de
l'inflation même si là ça a pas été fait
cet après-midi mais sur le sol européen
en érigeant la terrible guerre en
Ukraine ou la seule folie des marchés de
l'énergie fondée sur des règles
politiques absurdes et de dire que tout
sera serait les responsables de
l'envoler des prix il faut nommer les
choses
il faut parler de la cupidité de
certains qui s'enrichissent sur la
guerre se sert de prétexte relié ici ou
là pour enrayer l'ardente ambition
redistributive et non seulement il a été
refusé de mettre les entreprises à
contribution mais il nous a fallu les
aider massivement face au prix d'énergie
tout en préservant les marges celles qui
se sont gavées le bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité représente une dépense
supplémentaire de
18,3 milliards d'euros soit le surplus
phénoménal des dépenses budgétaires la
compensation induit d'électricité des
pertes baisse de prix atteste de cette
folie dépensière et ça c'est seulement
au service du capital les aides au
ménage supplémentaires par rapport à
2021 font pas le figure par rapport à
l'arrosage tous azimut d'argent public
pour pallier à la folie des marchés je
vous le dis l'État-providence s'est
transformé en 2022 en un état ambulance
des victimes de la marchandisation de la
société et en un état complice de la
hausse des profits sans partage au total
toute procède supplémentaire 43
milliards d'euros et toutes dépenses
supplémentaires 47,5 milliards d'euros
représentent une finnée 59,8% du déficit
constaté pour la Bible l'année 2022
c'est peu dire quand même que l'argent
existe et comme nous vous le disions
nous sommes passés du quoi qu'il en
coûte au quoiqu'il advienne les dépenses
publiques ont augmenté de 109,6
milliards d'euros par rapport à l'avant
pandémie et là franchement pour quelle
utilité sociale pour quelle progrès
sociaux si ce n'est des rameaux ici là
au détriment des l'intérêt des classes
moyennes et populaires qui en 2022 ont
eu le droit un chèque alors là un chèque
l'aide d'exceptionnel de solidarité pour
les plus précaires créant 1,3 millions
d'oubliés qui n'ont pas pu le recevoir
c'est insuffisant et je le dis révoltant
la sincérité budgétaire et politique se
manifestent également par des pratiques
d'affichage et alors là j'ai pris
l'exemple du plan de relance
un révélateur le plan de relance est
supplanté par un autre plan ces plans de
la communication la diminution de 7,3
milliards d'euros des crédit est
imputable en grande majorité par les
aides exceptionnelles à France
compétences ou Pôle emploi qu'il avait
d'ailleurs rien à voir avec la relance
3,7 milliards d'euros de cette économie
fictive a consisté à basculer les aides
à l'alternance visant à créer une
main-d'oeuvre gratuite vers un autre
programme budgétaire tout en faisant
coexister des dispositifs d'activités
partielles sur plusieurs programmes le
plan de relance a finance et des
dépenses qui n'avaient rien à voir avec
la relance le plan de relance c'est le
symbole des annonces alors là non suivi
des faits en 2021 24,9% et en 2022
34,1% des crédits n'ont pas été
consommés je cite la cour en raison de
dispositifs au financement plus complexe
que prévu ou qui ne trouve pas leur
public générant 6 milliards pour chacune
de ces deux années des reports de crédit
sur les années suivantes excusez-moi
mais peut-être que d'autres y
reviendront mais c'est toutes ces
dépenses vont pas concerner les
collectivités territoriales et
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre mais la
comparaison répétée plusieurs fois par
vous sur les contes administratifs des
collectivités territoriales et d'état et
je croyais que toutes les collectivités
territoriales de France ont les moyens
de l'État les moyens administratifs et
deuxièmement vous connaissez beaucoup de
collectivités territoriales qu'on mis en
débat des comptes administratifs qui
sont insincères avec un tel niveau de
report avec des telles prévisions qui
ont été erronées
vous en avez pas d'exemple parce que les
collectivités territoriales ont des
contaministratifs sincère cette année
encore 14,3 milliards ont été reportés
pour une politique ce que j'appelle une
politique de la cagnotte les
contreérités budgétaires les manœuvres
dilatoires et toutes les négations qu'on
a pu entendre tout ça ça aggrave la
situation de nos finances publiques donc
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs cette notion de rejet est un
outil que nous mettons à votre
disposition pour envoyer un message
clair le gouvernement est défaillant
dans ses prévisions il est défaillant
dans sa conception et ses réalisations
budgétaires cette défaillance s'appuie
sur une volonté politique insère nous
appelons à voter cette question
préalable pour que le prochain projet de
loi de finance soit différent votez
cette question préalable parce que les
erreurs d'hier font les déficits de
demain l'endettement d'après demain et
l'impossibilité d'investir pour la
transition écologique et les services
publics maintenant merci de votre
attention
merci chers collègues
quelle est la ville de la commission sur
le rapporteur général
c'est la vie défavorable pour plusieurs
raisons on peut partager les uns ou les
autres certains des arguments qui
viennent d'être développés mais
nous avons aussi envie de débattre
plutôt que de couper court à tout débat
ici sur les lois de règlement de 2021 et
de 2022 et puis peut-être aussi en
réponse
une partie du propos mais je veux redire
au ministre on peut pas tout à fait
comparer comme vous l'avez fait en
expliquant un peu sur un ton gentiment
professeur mais professeur al tout de
même ce qui a un compte administratif
que c'est l'exécution budgétaire etc ça
n'est pas que ça je vous ai donné
quelques exemples de
non-respects de l'esprit dans lequel des
mesures ont été votées et où finalement
le gouvernement s'est écarté et puis
le sujet des reports n'est pas mineur
donc
de notre point de vue c'est une c'est
aussi une manière de poser la question
au gouvernement
ça s'explique comment pourquoi garder
autant de réserves ça manque pour le
moins de bonnes exécutions budgétaires
de sobriété de rigueur bien ça mérite
dans notre assemblée d'en parler il y a
pas besoin d'y passer trois jours mais
le temps du débat que nous proposons
sera un temps utile merci avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis évidemment défavorable à cette
question préalable je redis monsieur le
rapporteur général n'ont pas du tout
avec un quelconque ton professoral que
ce soit mais en tant qu'avec mon
expérience que j'ai donné de conseiller
municipal comme beaucoup d'entre vous
ici que je fais le parallèle immédiat
avec le compte administratif et la
présentation du compte administratif
d'une commune j'entends que ça vous
dérange parce que c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de justifier qu'on vient
rejeter un texte qui ne fait que
présenter une photographie de
l'exécution des comptes de l'année
précédente c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de le justifier si ça n'était
pas que ça il y aura eu d'autres impacts
qu'un simple impact d'inscription
comptable au rejet de la loi de
règlement 2021 l'an dernier si ça avait
été un véritable texte budgétaire il y
aura eu un véritable impact sur notre
politique budgétaire ou sur notre
procédure budgétaire quand vous avez
rejeté une première fois le projet loi
de règlement l'an dernier ça n'a pas été
le cas tout simplement parce que ce
texte ne fait que traduire une
photographie des contes de l'année
précédente vous décidez de le rejeter
que ce soit par la question préalable ou
à l'issue du texte si j'ai pu entendre
les interventions qui ont été faites
vous pouvez l'assumer encore une fois en
démocratie heureusement et là je me
garderai bien de dire que c'est
illégitime ou de faire un procès entre
guillemets au choix que vous faites
simplement je dis mon incompréhension et
je continuerai à le dire sur ce texte là
comme sur le projet de loi d'approbation
des comptes de la Sécurité sociale qui
vient ensuite
merci explication de vote je n'en vois
pas je vous rappelle que
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la motion
tendance à opposer la question préalable
évidemment l'adoption de cette motion
entraînerait le rejet définitif du texte
en application de l'article 59 du
règlement le scrutin public ordinaire et
de droit le scrutin public sera ouvert
maintenant
elle qu'il s'agit d'un scrutin public
sur la motion tendance à opposer la
question préalable avec deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement
le scrutin est clos
votre temps 343 exprimé 279 pour 27
contre 252 la motion n'est pas adoptée
dans la suite de la discussion générale
commune la parole est à Madame Vanina
paoligajin pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances mes chers collègues
Pierre Mauroy disait que la rigueur
c'est l'austérité plus l'espoir
en terme mathématiques cette proposition
revient à l'opération suivante espoir
= rigueur moins austérité chaque texte
budgétaire que nous examinons confirme
l'équation mon roi loi de finance
initiale rectificative de règlement des
comptes et autres lois de programmation
tous ces textes suivent des procédures
millimétrées présentent des tableaux des
études d'impact des prévisions et des
ajustements et respectent des règles et
les carcans imposés par nos engagements
européens
bref tous ces textes Canada Dry ont la
couleur de la rigueur budgétaire sont le
goût de l'austérité
ainsi entretiennent-ils année après
année l'espoir d'une amélioration
prochaine qui s'apparente plutôt on doit
en convenir à une ivresse des
profondeurs
je n'en tiens pas rigueur si je puis
dire au gouvernement en tout cas pas à
vous monsieur le ministre car je sais
toute l'énergie que vous déployez pour
maîtriser les comptes
je sais aussi tout l'attachement de
notre commission des finances et
singulièrement de notre rapporteur
général à diminué les dépenses et la
dette publique
mais je crois sincèrement que nous
devons prendre acte mes chers collègues
d'un échec collectif notre approche pour
rigoureuse qu'elle paraisse ne nous
permet pas de changer la donne pour
reprendre le contrôle de nos comptes il
nous faut changer de logiciel et nous
astreindre à la rigueur
changer de logiciel qui crée une
approche intégrant l'impératif de
transformation écologique dans la
comptabilité budgétaire et donc une
analyse en valeur plutôt qu'en coût mais
c'est là un autre débat
revenons donc à la rigueur et là je
tiens à illustrer mon propos par un
exemple très précis en 2022 la charge de
la dette a augmenté de 12 milliards
d'euros
cette hausse est je ne parle pas de la
charge de la dette
au sens global mais seulement au cours
de 2022
et d'un montant supérieur à celui des
crédits de la mission plan de relance
sur le même exercice autrement dit le
poids de notre endettement bride notre
capacité à préparer le futur ne pas
réduire nos dépenses publiques si nous
empêcher d'investir à la fois dans nos
services publics essentiels dans les
technologies de rupture et dans notre
transformation écologique pour regagner
des marges de manoeuvre il nous faut
abaisser drastiquement d'autres dépenses
c'est tout le paradoxe à surmonté ces
équations difficiles sont des questions
d'arbitrage il ne s'agit pas seulement
de pointer du doigt tel ou tel dépense
mais bien d'opérer des arbitrages c'est
à dire d'indiquer des préférences
raisonner de façon globale et en
définitive faire des choix
c'est précisément ce que nous faisons
chaque automne c'est un moment fort de
la vie parlementaire et l'une des
prérogatives essentielles du Parlement à
savoir voter le budget
la constitution de notre cinquième
République ne prévoyait d'ailleurs à
l'origine je vous le rappelle que deux
sessions l'une budgétaire à l'automne et
l'autre législative aux beaux jours mais
précisément il me semble de bonne
politique de réserver les débats
budgétaires pour l'examen des projets de
loi de finance et le cas échéant des
projets de loi de finances
rectificatives un projet de loi de
règlement n'est pas censé être l'objet
de querelle politique il est de bonne
gestion d'arrêter en année N les contes
de l'année n-1 il ne me semble pas de
bonne politique de s'opposer à la
clôture des comptes
un projet de loi de règlement des
comptes n'a pas vocation à devenir un
règlement de compte politique adopter ce
texte n'est pas du tout souscrire aux
orientations budgétaires et politiques
qu'ils sous-tend c'est simplement
prendre acte des décisions passées en
responsabilité et dans le respect de nos
institutions j'ai moi-même indiqué les
réserves de notre groupe quant à la
situation de nos finances publiques
toutefois je doute que nous améliorions
les choses en rejetant ce texte or cela
doit rester notre sol préoccupation
faire repasser nos dépenses en deçà de
nos recettes et limiter le taux de nos
prélèvements obligatoires pour préserver
la compétitivité du site France
c'est la condition sinequanone mes chers
collègues pour rien industrialiser notre
pays et garder notre souveraineté
j'espère que le gouvernement nous
soumettra les économies récemment
annoncées et que notre commission sera
également force de proposition le groupe
Les Indépendants le sera en tous les cas
d'ici là notre groupe soutient les deux
projets de loi de règlement des comptes
pour les années 2021 et 2022 je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Daniel Breuillet
pour le groupe écologiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le Président de la Commission
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
d'abord je vais vous donner raison oui
les rejets des projets de loi de
règlement disent quelque chose de notre
démocratie Malo point mais ils n'ont
rien de pavlovien
monsieur le ministre je ne suis pas
certain de vous retrouver au prochain
projet loi de finances par pas que j'ai
eu écho de remaniement ministériel mais
je me dois de vous dire du coup une
nouvelle fois ma conviction profonde sur
les choix budgétaires qui ne répond ni
aux défis climatique ni aux défis
sociaux de notre pays la croisement de
la dette et la croisement de la charge
de la dette ne sont pas de bonne
nouvelle d'abord parce qu'elle diminue
la capacité d'agir de l'État les 13
milliards de hausse de la charge de la
dette aurait largement suffit à éviter
cette réforme injuste des retraites que
vous avez imposées aux français malgré
leur protestation constante mais la
dette n'est pas non plus mauvaise en soi
dès lors qu'elle est consacrée à des
investissements qui vont réduire notre
dépendance aux fossiles et notre déficit
extérieur c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous soutenons les propositions et les
constats du rapport pisaniferi mafuz
toutes les dettes ne sont pas bonnes
mais celles pour l'in pour le climat le
son s'endetter pour isoler les logements
du pays pour décarboner les transports
pour installer éoliennes et panneaux
solaires auraient un impact bénéfique
immédiat de plus nous nous privons de
recettes ou plutôt vous nous privez de
recettes puisque vous avez supprimé 50
milliards de recettes de TVA pour l'État
afin de compenser les recettes amputées
aux collectivités ou la redevance de
l'audiovisuel public ou encore la
suppression de la cvea aux entreprises
sans contrepartie c'est un très mauvais
scénario vous diminuez la capacité
d'agir de l'État et des collectivités la
qualité dans les services publics puis
vous pleurez que la dette augmente et
vous faites dire aux usagers via votre
plateforme en avoir pour mes impôts que
les services publics ne sont pas bons
nous nous privez plus de recettes
monsieur le ministre pour nous permettre
comme le précise le rapport Pisani
ferries Mafouz de relever le défi
climatique l'exécution budgétaire
reflète des petits pas et des
demi-mesures quand les dérèglements
climatiques avancent eux à grands pas et
à Fort bouleversement jusqu'à menacer la
ressource en eau de notre pays qui u
prédisent cela il nous faut entre 25 et
34 milliards d'euros de financement
public par an d'ici 2030 pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique et s'y
adapté vous avez écarté d'un revers de
main au tri SF climatique entendez la
proposition qui vous est faite d'appeler
à une contribution exceptionnelle et 10%
les plus aisés qui sont aussi les plus
pollueurs quand les plus modestes sont
ceux qui subissent le plus durement les
conséquences comme le Réseau Action
Climat nous estimons qu'il faut
davantage détailler l'analyse des
politiques de transition écologique sur
les inégalités sociales et la pauvreté
et avancer vers budget vers et sensible
aux inégalités la Cour des comptes a
d'ailleurs qualifié le budget vert
annexé au projet de loi de règlement de
démarche inabouties c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire quand le bouclier est
arrivé de 45 milliards d'euros n'a pas
été intégré dans les dépenses
défavorables au climat alors qu'il
constitue une aide à la consommation
d'énergie fossiles donnons-nous les
moyens de réellement évaluer nos actions
et de les infléchir notre regroupe
renouvelle sa demande d'une loi de
programmation des financements de la
transition écologique car il y a urgence
face au covid vous aviez pris des
mesures exceptionnelles c'est mesures
exceptionnelles sont aujourd'hui
indispensables face à la crise
climatique dans la gravité n'est pas
moindre notre groupe défend également le
service public qui est le patrimoine de
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
l'affaiblissement continue des services
publics dans les territoires ruraux
comme dans les quartiers populaires
aboutit un sentiment d'abandon et de
désespérance que les gilets jaunes la
crise actuelle révèle avec violence il y
a urgence de plus et de mieux de
services publics et de plus de
solidarité lorsque l'inflation en grande
partie spéculative attaquent le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens enfin elle se
sera mon dernier point il y a une
insincérité des documents présentés et
je pense à tous les reports de crédit
les écarts dans les proportions
historiques qui malmènent les droits du
Parlement sur l'élaboration et le
contrôle budgétaire dans un climat dans
un contexte d'urgence climatique et
d'augmentation des inégalités et budget
2021 et 2022 sont des occasions manquées
pour les services publics comme pour la
transition les profits et les dividendes
records auraient pu servir au
financement d'une véritable bifurcation
environnementale et sociale vous vous
privez de recettes fiscale mais la crise
climatique ne repassera pas des plats et
l'insuffisance action aujourd'hui se
traduira par des crises aggravées demain
c'est pourquoi nous désapp rouvons ces
projets de loi de règlement si chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
monsieur Julien barjoton pour le groupe
RDPI pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
je vais essayer bref non pas pour
abréger nos souffrances mais puisque le
ministre n'a pas réussi à vous
convaincre je pense que j'aurais du mal
à le faire également je vais quand même
essayer
il n'y a jamais eu de rejet par les deux
chambres des lois de règlement depuis
1833 1833 c'est à dire 190 ans
quand le baron de Montbel a présenté ses
comptes c'est vrai qu'il y avait eu
entre temps les trentes glorieuses et
que et bien l'assemblée qui avait suivi
et le Sénat avait rejeté ses comptes en
1833 il y a 190 ans pourtant depuis la
France a quand même vécu des périodes
politiques compliquées or et étendu et
mon attention or pour autant malgré
cette longue vie politique jamais les
deux chambres n'avaient voté contre des
projets loi de règlement on est quand
même pas tout à fait dans la situation
du 19e siècle ou du 20e siècle et
pourtant dans ces moments-là et bien ça
ne s'était pas produit
donc je ne peux y voir qu'un acte
politique bon qui se produit parfois
dans les collectivités locales mais pas
toujours pas toujours je trouve que moi
j'étais adjoint au finance d'une grande
collectivité locale il a dessus les
oppositions avaient des attitudes
différentes il y a eu des moments où ils
n'ont pas voté mais il y a des moments
où certains des opposants y compris des
opposants très durs et les filles
aujourd'hui devenus députés d'ailleurs
qui disait je suis tout à fait contre
votre budget mais le compte
administratif c'est pas mon affaire
c'est pas mon affaire c'est votre
gestion c'est la façon dont vous avez
fait appliquer par vos services votre
projet politique et autant certaines
oppositions pas tout le temps étaient
extrêmement virulentes pendant le budget
mais ensuite disait le compte
administratif on va pas voilà remettre
en cause la façon dont ça s'est passé là
c'est pas le choix que vous faites et
évidemment je ne peux qu'il y ait une
lecture une lecture politique et c'est
d'ailleurs honorable c'est votre choix
mais mais ne la sous-estimez pas c'est
ça que je vais vous dire ne dites pas
que finalement ce serait normal ou banal
ou expliquer par des raisons de fonds ça
n'a pas été le cas pendant 190 ans que
les deux chambres le fassent donc il y a
quand même eu d'autres d'autres périodes
évidemment moi sur le fond vous
comprenez que je que je partage ce qu'il
y a dans la 2021 2022 2021 c'était le
moment de la relance fondre solidarité à
l'occasion chômage soutien en ménage etc
les pays à doubler bon l'accompagnement
de la relance et 2022 c'est le budget de
la lutte contre les conséquences de
l'inflation donc dans ces deux cas moi
je me réjouis que le gouvernement est
mené les actions qu'il est qu'il a pu
mener notamment sur les chats carburant
etc pour limiter l'impact pour nos
concitoyens de de l'inflation au-delà de
ça sur le fond par rapport à ce que j'ai
entendu je voudrais quand même rappeler
que la baisse de l'IS de l'impôt soit la
société paradoxalement a permis
d'engranger beaucoup plus de recettes
d'impôts sur les sociétés 22 milliards
de plus que ce qui était prévu donc ça
veut dire qu'effectivement bien
finalement un moindre taux rapporte plus
de base plus de recettes comme c'est
souvent c'est souvent le cas et puis en
2022 la croissance a quand même été de
2,6%, vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
monsieur le rapporteur général et dans
le contexte obtenu une croissance de
2,6%, c'est bien que les actions
entreprises ont pu fonctionner donc
voilà moi ce que ce qui fait que notre
groupe votera parce que sur le fond nous
partageons le constat que dresse ces
projets loi règlement mais encore une
fois au-delà de ça c'est une
photographie
administrative et le fait de faire NPPV
ou de s'abstenir comme le font beaucoup
d'oppositions ça je je ne peux que le
confirmer avec mon expérience des locaux
nous sommes tous des locaux ça
permettrait de faire passer le texte et
donc de pouvoir régler les questions
administratives et donc ne pas obliger
le gouvernement à chaque fois trouver
quelque chose pour pouvoir faire ensuite
adopter le bilan ce qui est un peu parce
que contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre la Cour des comptes à certifié
et nulle part ne partent dans sa sérité
moi j'ai entendu le mot dans sincérité
pas dans toutes les bouches il faut bien
le dire mais en tout cas pour celles et
ceux qui ont prononcé le mot d'insin
sincérité ça il faut vraiment le récuser
parce que la Cour des comptes a certifié
donc il n'y aurait pas d'insécurité
particulière qui justirait qui
justifierait un acte politiquement fort
qui est le rejet par les deux Chambres
inédit depuis 1833 de ce projet de loi
règlement voilà vous voulez en faire un
moment à mon avis qui n'est pas très
pertinent d'opposition au gouvernement
alors même qu'on a tout le débat
budgétaire qui nous permet largement
d'avoir ce débat démocratique et
notamment ce débat démocratique
d'opposition pour celles et ceux qui ne
partagent pas les projets politiques qui
sont traduits par un budget je regrette
la position du Sénat aujourd'hui je
trouve que la période ne justifie pas
d'avoir recours à un moyen qui n'a
jamais été je lui dis et tu disais
depuis 190 ans et puis j'espère que le
gouvernement et bien trouvera les
solutions
pour que on puisse avoir ensuite un
bilan un bilan de l'état comme comme
c'est nécessaire parce que au bout de
plusieurs années peut-être que ça
finirait par poser un certain nombre de
difficultés merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues si vous me le
permettez Monsieur barjoton pour les
très nombreux téléspectateurs qui nous
suivent en 1833 c'est la chambre des
pères il y a pas de Sénat et il y a une
chambre des députés il y a une chambre
des députés pas d'assemblée nationale
respectant le calendrier merci
la parole est maintenant madame Isabelle
briquet pour le groupe socialiste pour 9
minutes
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre lors de nos différents échanges
et encore à l'instant vous comparez
souvent les lois de règlement au compte
administratif de nos collectivités qui
traduisent ou droit ou doivent traduire
l'exécution budgétaire d'un exercice
donné c'est effectivement très
majoritairement le cas et bien souvent
les contes administratifs sont approuvés
par des élus n'ayant absolument pas
validé les choix budgétaires mis en
oeuvre
jusqu'ici le raisonnement tient à une
condition près que l'exécution
budgétaire correspond bien aux
prévisions données et de ce point de vue
là Monsieur le Ministre forcer de
constater que cette logique n'est pas au
rendez-vous concernant les deux projets
de loi de règlement soumis à notre
examen
nous retrouvons donc sans réelle
surprise le projet loi de règlement 2021
en Suisse de l'approbation des comptes
pour l'année 2022 à l'ordre du jour de
nos débats
le projet de loi de règlement du budget
pour un 2021 que nous avons déjà rejeté
l'été dernier n'ayant pas connu
l'évolution majeure et l'on voit mal
comment aurait pu être le cas appellera
de notre part une conclusion
identique
rappelons que le rejet de ce texte était
largement motivé par de nombreux
éléments remettant en cause la sincérité
budgétaire la Cour des comptes soulevée
déjà une atteinte au principe
d'annualité et de spécialités
budgétaires en effet le niveau des un
des reports de crédit environ 23
milliards la confusion des exercices
budgétaires l'utilisation répétée des
crédits de programme budgétaire pour
financer des dépenses relevant d'autres
programmes ne pouvait que nuire à la
lisibilité de ce texte visibilité
pourtant indispensable pour démontrer
l'efficacité de la politique menée sauf
à vouloir habilement camoufler son échec
plus grave encore la logique employée
n'affecte pas seulement la crédibilité
du gouvernement elle a également un
impact réel sur nos concitoyens en
freinant la circulation d'argent et en
ne permettant pas d'investir dans
l'économie l'ensemble des crédits qui
devraient l'être je ne vais pas
reprendre ici l'ensemble des points
défaillants de ce projet de loi de
règlement 2021 ils sont nombreux et ont
conduit au rejet de ce texte par
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat cette
situation inédite sous la Cinquième
République aurait dû selon toute
vraisemblance inspirez le gouvernement
afin qu'elle ne se reproduise pas mais
de ce point de vue je ne prendrai pas
les paris
manifestement aucun enseignement ne
semble avoir été tiré de l'expérience
passée le projet loi de réglement 2022
reproduisant les mêmes pratiques
budgétaires les mêmes causes entraînant
les mêmes effets le groupe socialiste ne
validera pas davantage les comptes de
l'exercice 2022
lors de l'examen du projet loi de
finances pour 2022 notre groupe c'était
opposé à la poursuite du désarmement
fiscal engagé par la majorité
présidentielle doublé d'une absence
d'ambition réelle en matière de
politique publique tant en ce qui
concerne la cohésion sociale et
territoriale qu'en matière de transition
écologique dont l'urgence pourtant
s'impose à tous ce projet loi de
règlement pour 2022 aggrave ses manques
en actant cette année encore des
montants disproportionnés d'annulation
et de report de crédit à hauteur de 18
milliards au détriment de politiques
publiques essentielles à titre exemples
parmi les 9,8 milliards d'euros
d'annulation de crédit la mission
écologique se voit amputer de 714
millions d'euros qui auraient pu
aisément amorcer l'effort vers la
transition écologique
nous venons de discuter il y a quelques
jours du projet de loi industriels et
nous voyons bien que la question du
financement d'un nouveau modèle
économique est important à plusieurs
titres
c'est pourquoi nos propositions
d'équilibre d'équilibrage fiscaux tel
que l'isfaire jusqu'à leur écarté mais
nous ne désespérons pas font montre de
leur pertinence car l'enjeu ici dépasse
de loin l'aspect financier la réussite
de la transition écologique dépendra
aussi de son acceptabilité sociale
il serait dommage de ne pas l'entendre
mais compter sur nous en la matière nous
saurons faire preuve de pédagogie
s'il est à noter la diminution du
déficit public qui passe de 6 et demi à
4,7% du PIB la part du solde structurel
dans le dans le déficit public reste
inquiétante et marque la nécessité pour
l'État et nos services publics de
retrouver des marges de manœuvre
financières cette année encore
l'importance du déficit structurel 3,4%
témoignent une fois de plus de l'impasse
budgétaire du gouvernement du fait de
son refus obstiné d'engager une
quelconque réponse en matière de
rééquilibrage des recettes de l'État
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
alerte même sur le fait que ce déficit
structurel pourrait se dégrader
davantage
étant donné l'état de nos finances
publiques alors que de nouvelles
dépenses devront être financées la
question des recettes nous pourra sans
cesse être
occultées
si l'on peut entendre et même partager
le souci de maîtrise de dépenses
publiques
force est de constater l'impasse fiscal
de ce gouvernement qui refuse avec une
constance qui interroge de faire
contribuer les entreprises et les plus
aisées à la solidarité nationale alors
même que rapport après rapport
l'ensemble des analyses témoignent de
l'unification de la théorie du
ruissellement si souvent mis en avant
dans un tel contexte était-il sérieux de
se priver de recettes comme le prévoyait
cette année encore la loi de finances
initiale chez la faiblesse de croire que
les 50 milliards d'impôts auxquels le
gouvernement a renoncé ces dernières
années aurait été effort utile et
pourtant loin de changer de braquer de
nouveaux cadeaux fiscaux sont envisagés
jusqu'à quand nos finances publiques
pourront-elles supporter cette vision
purement idéologique
au-delà même des suppressions d'impôts
aux taxes tels que la taxe d'habitation
la CVAE et dernièrement la redevance sur
l'audiovisuel public que nous avons
combattu leur compensation par des
fractions TVA pose question
jusqu'à quand l'État pourra-t-il se
priver de recettes dynamique alors que
notre dette atteint les 3000 milliards
vous allez me dire monsieur le ministre
à l'appui de vos choix de réduction
d'impôts en faveur des entreprises que
le produit de l'impôt sur les sociétés
sont trouvés grandement améliorées s'il
est vrai que les recettes de l'impôt sur
les sociétés marque une progression
nette en 2022 il convient de rappeler
que ces recettes sont particulièrement
sensibles à la conjoncture et donc
forcément fluctuante en revanche une
chose est sûre le désarmement fiscal
continue ne permettra pas à l'état
d'assurer des politiques publiques
ambitieuses pour notre pays et renforcer
nos services publics il est urgent de
réorganiser la solidarité nationale nous
renforcer la puissance publique de
lutter contre les inégalités qui ne
cessent de se creuser et fracture notre
société
pour l'heure ainsi que nous avons pu le
voir
ce projet de loi de règlement pour 2022
ressemble beaucoup à la mouture 2021
comme l'an passé la Cour des comptes n'a
d'ailleurs pas manqué de relever que
l'ampleur des annulations et des reports
de crédit pose problème estimant que
cette situation était de nature à
remettre en cause le principe
d'annualité budgétaire en effet si ces
reports expliquent pour partie
s'explique pour partie par le contexte
économique et social il témoigne aussi
de l'absence des progrès du gouvernement
en matière d'engagement concret des
dépenses votées par le Parlement
ce projet de loi de règlement 2022 comme
en 2021 marque une exécution budgétaire
éloignée de l'autorisation parlementaire
mais avant tout signe une nouvelle fois
l'entêtement idéologique du gouvernement
dans une politique purement libérale
dont les résultats ne sont pas la
hauteur des enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux le groupe socialiste
rejettera donc les projets loi de
règlement et d'approbation des comptes
publics pour 2021 et 2022 je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant Monsieur
Eric Bocquet pour le groupe CRCE pour 5
minutes
mes chers collègues alors où les
associations d'élus locaux
départementaux et régionaux ont refusé
de participer à la grand-messe de
l'austérité qui se tenait sous la
bannière d'assise des finances publiques
je souhaite au nom de notre groupe leur
témoigner tout notre soutien
dire que nous ne laisserons pas faire
les décisions non concertées unilatérale
comme l'indispensable revalorisation du
point d'indice sans moyen nouveau dire
que le concept très bercien
d'auto-assurance revient non plus à
s'attaquer aux dépenses et collectivités
comme le faisait les contrats de Cahors
sur lesquels le gouvernement s'est
obstiné mais sur les recettes cette
fois-ci les obligeantes à créer des
réserves en gros le message collectivité
et le suivant tu ne pourras compter que
sur toi-même le ministre Bruno Le Maire
dans une formule dont il a le secret fin
de se demander aujourd'hui qui est
l'assureur en dernier ressort des
collectivités locales c'est l'État les
collectivités territoriales face à cette
affront régiment une irresponsabilité
fantasmée des élus n'ont pas besoin de
cette assureur que serait l'état celui
qui les a laissé tomber abandonner face
aux méandres du marché européen de
l'énergie et de l'explosion des denrées
alimentaires nourris pour moitié par la
course au profit
la loi de règlement pour 2022 c'est
l'occasion de regarder quelle assureur
fut l'état quant au Sénat Monsieur le
Maire sous les houras de l'hémicycle
s'extasier devant le filet de sécurité
je cite ainsi plus de la moitié des
communes françaises seront éligibles à
ce dispositif je veux saluer une fois
encore l'esprit constructif et de
compromis ayant présidé à la rédaction
de cet amendement et de ce
sous-amendement qui permettent selon moi
de protéger le bloc communal contre les
conséquences de l'inflation fin de
citation lors du débat sur les finances
locales en amont du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 l'ex ministre chargé
des collectivités confirmait ses propos
dès cet été le gouvernement a proposé
des mesures fortes dans la loi de
finances rectificative que vous avez
enrichi et voté je pense en particulier
au filet de sécurité de 430 millions
d'euros pour aider les communes et les
intercommunalités les plus fragiles à
faire face à la hausse du point d'indice
et des prix de l'alimentation et de
l'énergie fin de citation des 430
millions promis ce filet de sécurité
trop complexe et restrictif n'a
finalement généré que 106 millions
d'euros de soutien moins d'un quart donc
quand au nombre de communes vous lui
direz monsieur le ministre si les 22000
communes éligibles telles qu'affirmés à
l'époque en ont effectivement bénéficié
la situation est pourtant extrêmement
gras pour les collectivités notamment
les collectivités locales qui ont vu
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement bondir
de 6% après 2,8% en 2021 l'indice des
prix à la consommation alimentaire
augmentait de 12,1% sur l'année et
l'énergie de 15,1%
le Comité des finances locales a calculé
que les charges externes et le poste de
dépenses qui a le plus augmenté avec
11,1%, par le haut par l'augmentation de
30% pour l'ensemble énergie électricité
combustible et carburants ce sont près
de 4 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
que les communes ont dépensé sur ce seul
poste budgétaire que sont les 106
millions d'euros à côté avec un casigel
la DGF qui diminue en volume à mesure
que croit l'inflation les dépenses
personnelles bondissent elles aussi de
4,9% après 2,5 notamment du fait de la
revalorisation du point d'indice et la
revalorisation des carrières des agents
de catégorie C un phénomène analogue
traverse les départements d'outre-mer
avec une explosion de leur charge
externe de 11,2% à la Réunion et 6,9 un
Mayotte dont les communes du territoire
sont affectées par une augmentation des
dépenses de personnel deux fois
supérieures à la métropole
je ne reviens pas sur tous les
indicateurs financiers si ce n'est en
disant que l'investissement a augmenté
de 10,7%, un montant anormal entre
guillemets à cette période du fait de
l'envoler des prix des matériaux
réduisant de 2 milliards à 0,5 milliards
lotofinancement des communes les 100
planner un avenir sombre sur
l'investissement public pourtant moteur
de la croissance économique il est temps
d'instaurer un moratoire sur les baisses
fiscalités locales de soutenir les
collectivités non pas comme un assureur
mais dans un pacte financier renouvelé
respectueux entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales impact dans
lequel il n'y aurait ni Cahors ni
injonction ni TVA pour ce lien entre la
fiscalité et la valeur ajoutée parlons
de sécurité financière sans filet
parlons-en cette loi de règlement nous a
donné l'occasion d'évaluer une mesure
que vous avez voulu emblématique de
votre soutien au bloc local mais qui n'a
pas sinon bien trop peu permis aux
collectivités d'affronter en 2022 les
aléas des marchés mondiaux et une
conject ure une conjoncture défavorable
dans le cadre budgétaire de gel et
dotation que vous avez instaurées je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Michel Canevet pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 8 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues au nom du
groupe de l'Union centriste je n'aurais
pas une lecture aussi négative de ces
lois de règlement que celle que je viens
d'entendre à l'instant rassurez-vous
monsieur le ministre il y a quand même
un certain nombre d'éléments positifs
dans ce qui s'est passé la dépasser
d'abord
un déficit du budget de l'État qui était
assez proche de celui qui avait été
prévu en loi de finance initiale il
était à 2 milliards quatre inférieurs à
ce qui avait été prévu en loi de finance
2000 2023 2022 pardon et
de surcroît
j'ai perdu le fil de mon propos mais je
vais le retrouver bien entendu qui
n'était pas aussi négatif une inflation
qui a pu être maîtrisée on l'a bien vu
par rapport aux autres pays européens
nous avons une situation beaucoup plus
favorable que dans autres dans les
autres pays européens ceci grâce à
l'intervention de l'État notamment et il
faut s'en féliciter parce que c'est vrai
que nous avons connu une année avec
beaucoup de rebondissements et en
particulier et en 2022 la guerre en
Ukraine qui a amené des conséquences
extrêmement fortes sur la vie dans notre
pays et dans le reste du monde avec une
inflation du coût de l'énergie qui a
pesé sur l'activité sur les entreprises
bien entendu mais aussi sur l'ensemble
des particuliers et on doit dire que les
uns et les autres ont pu surmonter cela
grâce notamment à la au soutien de
l'État en ces périodes difficiles
alors malgré cela il faut quand même
nous inquiéter de la situation d'abord
parce que nous avons un déficit ces deux
dernières années qui étaient assez
conséquences 170 milliards en 2021 151
milliards en 2022 c'est que ce sont
quand même des chiffres tout à fait
important conséquents et donc il ne faut
nous en préoccuper ceci induit une
augmentation de la dette de notre pays
elle a atteint 3000 milliards voilà peu
et donc là aussi les conséquences sont
assez importantes pour notre pays parce
que ça se traduit notamment dans le
contexte de hausse des taux d'intérêt
que nous avons connus par une charge des
intérêts de la dette qui devient tout à
fait significative à 50 milliards
d'euros de charges d'intérêt de la dette
cela pèse considérablement dans le
budget de notre pays et ce que nous
pouvons craindre c'est si nous
continuons ainsi à devoir nous en en
permanence c'est que cette charge des
intérêts de la dette devienne le poste
de dépenses le plus important du budget
de l'État et ceci serait préoccupant
parce que cela a été dit avant moi bien
entendu il y a des investissements à
réaliser pour que nous préparions
l'avenir les investissements ce sont
notamment les investissements de
formation et il est heureux que le
premier poste de dépenses de l'État soit
aujourd'hui le budget de l'Éducation
nationale il faut qu'il reste le premier
poste de dépenses de l'État mais ceci ne
pourra continuer ne pourra intervenir
que si la charge des intérêts de la
dette ne croit pas et donc nous avons à
être envahi particulier sur ce plan là
et c'est un peu le sens de l'alerte que
nous souhaitons au niveau du groupe de
l'Union centriste lancé au gouvernement
alors ce que l'on constate donc cette
année 2022 de surcroît
c'est que
la situation donc est particulièrement
difficile au niveau des recettes on se
réjouit bien entendu que nous ayons pu
adopter une trajectoire qui conduise à
la réduction des impôts c'est ce que
tout le monde souhaite parce qu'on voit
bien la France est aujourd'hui parmi les
pays les plus endettés au monde parmi
les
fiscalité et la plus élevée au monde
donc il importe que nous puissions
corriger cette trajectoire ça a été fait
notamment sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
sans que pour autant cela se traduise et
cela a été dit avant moi par une baisse
des recettes bien au contraire les
recettes ont augmenté mais donc on peut
se réjouir que quand on baisse des
impôts on arrive quand même à augmenter
les recettes mais ceci dans un contexte
économique où la situation était plutôt
bonne alors nous le disons clairement
monsieur le ministre au niveau du groupe
de l'Union centriste
en 2022 nous aurions souhaité que sur un
certain nombre de
alors cela n'a pas été le cas et le fait
d'avoir anticipé monsieur le ministre
très clairement cette suppression de la
redevance parce qu'elle était prévue par
le Président de la République il est
normal de la réaliser mais nous aurions
pu décaler dans le temps ce qui nous
aurait permis certainement de pouvoir
avoir une situation financière un tout
petit peu améliorée et nous avions
également proposé monsieur le ministre
que la suppression de la CVU une mesure
que nous partageons bien entendu mais il
nous semblait important compte tenu de
la situation des finances publiques à
l'époque de la décaler également dans le
temps ce qui aurait permis de retrouver
quelques mars de manœuvre parce que la
difficulté c'est que nous nous
retrouvons maintenant à la préparation
du budget 2024 avec la nécessité de
trouver
8 à 10 milliards d'économies et la Cour
des comptes prévoit dans sa publication
de jeudi dernier la nécessité de trouver
60 milliards d'économies d'ici 2027 et
on voit bien que la
la difficulté pour trouver des économies
et donc il importe que nous puissions là
aussi trouver les recettes qui
permettent conserver les recettes qui
permettent de réduire cela parce que
nous avons des besoins extrêmement
importants on l'a vu lorsqu'on a voté
vendredi jeudi dernier la loi de
programmation militaire qui prévoit un
effort sans précédent on le voit aussi
sur un grand nombre de nos dépenses
budgétaires je pense à la police je
pense à la justice je pense à l'aide
publique au développement ce sont des
secteurs qui vont demander un effort à
cru on le voit bien pour ce qui concerne
la police notamment par la situation que
nous connaissons la politique de la
ville sans doute devra aussi nécessiter
un certain nombre de crédits
supplémentaires pour apporter des
réponses aux mal-être que l'on a
ressenti donc on voit que sur de
nombreux secteurs et je n'oublie pas
bien entendu la nécessité de la
transition énergétique qui appelle là
aussi 50 à 60 milliard d'investissement
par an tout ceci ne pourra se faire que
si l'État est en capacité d'accompagner
les projets et les mesures à mettre en
oeuvre alors trouver des mesures
d'économie dans le budget difficile
aujourd'hui alors que nous avons des
besoins importants montrent bien
l'ampleur de la difficulté ceci étant le
groupe de l'Union centriste dans sa très
grande majorité ça je tiendra sur ces
projets de loi de règlement seul de
collègues Vincent Delahaye et Jean-Marie
maison partisan du Driel orthodoxie
budgétaire voteront contre les autres
s'absiendront où votre concours
absolument merci de votre attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Christian bilak pour le groupe RDS ce
pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur rapporteur général le
président est plus là mes chers
collègues mercredi dernier commencer
deux lois de règlement pour le prix
d'une
le projet de loi de règlement du budget
pour 2021 revient devant le Sénat après
des rochers
une année de gestion de crise sanitaire
avec plus de 40 milliards d'euros dédiés
à payer la facture du quoiqu'il en coûte
il s'est caractérisé par des dépenses
nécessaires pour affronter une crise des
joies toutes les prévisions et je dirais
simplement pour 2021 en situation
exceptionnelle décision exceptionnelle
[Musique]
mais comme il est difficile d'évoquer un
5 minutes de loi de règlement
budgétaires mon intervention portera
surtout sur la loi de règlement pour
2022 qui se résume ainsi
151 milliards d'euros de déficit le nom
respect des grands principes de la
comptabilité publique
la crise sanitaire passée on aurait pu
espérer que le budget pour 2022 ça
ressentirait par une baisse les 34
milliards du plan d'urgence sanitaire
pour devenir disparu et les 7 milliards
économisés du pas de l'orage en 2022
représente 41 milliards d'euros
une partie de ces sommes a été
réinjectée vers les 36 milliards de la
mission écologique développement et
mobilité durable 11 de plus qu'en 2021
consacré au bouclier énergétique contre
l'os des prix du gaz et de l'électricité
l'objectif de redressement des finances
publiques s'éloigne on passe de
360 milliards de dépasses nains de
budget général en 2019
à 445 milliards en peine le fer 2022
soit une offre considérable de 23,7%
par ailleurs si on peut noter que les
concours collectivités sont en os avec
un total de 43 milliards c'est un
évolution en réalité en trompe l'oeil
car il ne s'agit que de compenser les
suppressions d'impôts
et au sujet des collectivités je ne
reviendrai pas le rapporteur l'a fait
sur les crédits routiers
les recettes fiscales sont Amos de 7
milliard et demi en 2022 mais j'invite à
la prudence car l'écart entre prévisions
réalisation est devenu une tradition
l'exécution du budget 2022 se
carrejecteur d'homme par une situation
très dreadrée des codes publics où
l'endettement atteint des sommet
plusieurs facteurs expliquent la
difficulté à redresser la situation avec
l'inflation l'offe des taux d'intérêt
alourdis le coût de la dette malgré une
légère baisse de rachelendettement qui
passe le sang en virgule le chiffre du
PIB contre 112 9 en 2021
le déficit effectif s'établit à 4,5 du
PIB et pour mémoire si on se penche sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques 2018-2019
le déficit prévu était de 0,3 0,3
4,7 je vous joins de financement reste
élevé et pour y répondre 260 milliards
d'euros de dettes en moyenne et long
terme ont été mis en 2022 les dépenses
brutes augmentent de 21,3 milliards par
rapport à 2021 pour atteindre
578,4 milliards d'euros les trois
premiers postes de dépenses restent
l'enseignement scolaire avait 78,5
milliards d'euros de crédit de paiement
mais ensuite on trouve les engagements
fidèles à l'échelle de l'État la dette
avec
54,3 milliards d'euros
passant devant les 51,7 milliards du
budget de la défense
en conclusion je vous dirais monsieur le
ministre qu'il faut garder en tête
l'objectif du redressement des finances
publiques nous en sommes encore loin
dans ce contexte le groupe rdhe votera
majorité en faveur du projet de loi de
règlement du 2021 budget exceptionnel
mesure exceptionnelle et ça tiendra
majorité pour 2022
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Madame Christine l'avare pour
le groupe les républicains pour 7
minutes
[Applaudissements]
alors vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre l'analyse des contes 2022
permet de dresser une photographie de
l'économie française et ben j'aimerais
vous dire qu'on aimerait avoir une plus
belle image à regarder en effet
l'amélioration relative du déficit parce
que quand même moins 4,7% ou moins près
de 125 milliards repose sur la seule
dynamique très forte des recettes
fiscales supérieures à la dynamique je
suis obligé de le dire récurrente des
dépenses alors même que les prélèvements
se recètent au profit de l'Union
européenne et des collectivités locales
sont en baisse moins 2,4 milliards
d'euros inclus en cumulé au sujet des
collectivités je ne peux pas d'ailleurs
manquer de souligner que c'est
d'ailleurs son financés à 93,4% par la
voix d'affectation d'impôts et de
prélèvements sur recettes
les recettes publiques représentent
53,4% du PIB ce chiffre est le même en
2018 et en 2022 mais cette stabilité
cache un niveau historique pour les
prélèvements obligatoires qui atteignent
45,3% du PIB je pense qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de se réjouir le déficit structurel
tenant compte de la dernière évaluation
du PIB potentiel présenté dans le
rapport économique et social et
financier pour 2023 et de 4%. le déficit
structurel pour 2023 est également de 4%
il n'y aura il n'y aurait donc aucune
amélioration du déficit structurel entre
2022 et 2023 à moins d'une très bonne
surprise le Conseil des finances
publiques tire pourtant la syneste
d'alarme et je le cite une nette
réduction du déficit structurel est
nécessaire pour réduire l'exposition de
la France à un risque d'insoutenabilité
de sa dette alors que de nouvelles
dépenses publiques devront être
financées notamment en faveur de la
transition énergétique et des
investissements pour renforcer la
croissance et au titre des lois de
programmation sectorielle votée ou
déposées elle suppose une action résolue
sur la dépense publique et tout ceci
avant la visite du président à Marseille
ou encore les événements de ces derniers
jours
je poursuis l'amélioration affichée du
sol de budgétaire - 151 milliards après
- 170 milliards en 2021 et - 178
milliards en 2020 contre - 93 milliards
en 2019 ne résulte pas d'un effort de
gestion mais seulement d'un effort en
paiement la comptabilité budgétaire
parmi en effet de reporter le paiement
de certaines factures sur l'exercice
suivant tout en reportant les crédits
ainsi 25 milliards de crédits n'ont pas
été consommés et 18 milliards ont été
reportés ceci conduit un constat sévère
de la Cour des comptes la gestion 2022
prolonge ce qui avait observé en 2020 et
2021 une tendance marquée à la
budgétisation d'enveloppe importante qui
apparaissent sous consommer en cours
d'année reporté sur l'exercice suivant
et parfois en partie redéployer cette
tendance porte atteinte au principe
d'annualité elle pose aussi question au
regard du principe de spécialité deux
surcroît elle nu à la lisibilité de
l'autorisation parlementaire en générale
ou comptabilité d'engagement la
situation est beaucoup moins favorable
le solde se dégrade entre les deux
exercices de 4,5 milliards en effet les
dépenses de fonctionnement ont augmenté
de près de 15 milliards par rapport à
2021 citons pêle-mêle 10 milliards pour
la renationalisation de DF 4 milliards
de subventions à France compétences dont
le sous-financement est structurel et à
ce sujet j'ai bien noté que le
gouvernement envisage d'adopter dans le
PLF pour 2024 une mesure que j'ai porté
dans cette hémicycle à l'occasion du PLF
pour 2023 un an perdu 1,9 milliards pour
financer l'amortissement de la dette de
l'État ce ne sont pas des dépenses
d'avenir monsieur le ministre mais ce
sont des dépenses pour sauver des
bateaux en train de couler par ailleurs
les lois de programmation sectorielles
ont eu un effet à hauteur de 70
milliards en 2022 mais en 2023 c'est
déjà près de 20% de la dépense qui est
déjà prêt engagé
la dépense de l'État en 2022 est ainsi
supérieure de 109 milliards +
31,9% par rapport à 2019 alors que
l'inflation sur la même période n'a été
que de
8,6%. quand je parle d'inflation bien
naturellement je poursuis avec la dette
la hausse du service de la dette en 2022
n'est qu'un apéritif en effet la hausse
intérêts a eu un effet nul en 2022 ce ne
sera plus vrai au cours des prochains
exercices budgétaires une augmentation
de 1% du taux moyen se traduit par un
surcoût de 15 milliards à 5 ans et de 31
milliards à 10 ans par ailleurs le
roulement de la dette va être très
rapide au cours des prochaines années
50% de la dette à moyen terme doit avoir
été remboursé en 2028 et près de 75%
d'ici 2032
monsieur le ministre je voudrais aussi
vous parler du schéma d'emploi qui
contribue en 2022 à la modération de la
masse salariale mais c'est en fait une
source d'inquiétude parce que pour
mémoire la loi de finances initiale pour
2022 prévoyait une légère hausse des
effectifs de l'État la baisse constatée
plus forte qu'en 2021 avec moins
5700 emplois et porté par les ministères
de l'Éducation nationale et celui des
armées or les effectifs de ces deux
ministères auraient dû augmenter avec
moins 4400 ETP du fait des demi-tions de
difficultés de recrutement la situation
devient critique à l'éducation nationale
alors même que le niveau des élèves
continue de baisser et que les résultats
au dernier concours de recrutement vont
plutôt de mal en PI il est urgent
monsieur le ministre au regard de tous
ces éléments d'avoir une trajectoire de
référence avec l'adoption d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
engagent vraiment l'État mais aussi
l'ensemble des acteurs publics dans une
stratégie de redressement de nos
finances
cette année encore le groupe les
républicains dans sa majorité ne votera
pas cette loi de règlement traduction
d'une loi de finances qu'il n'a pas
soutenu ce vote vise aussi à dénoncer le
mépris du Parlement par une remise en
cause des principes de nualité de
spécificité j'ai déjà évoqué les reports
de crédit massif d'un exercice sur
l'autre 2022 inoffre puisque ces
enveloppes ne sont plus inscrites ne
sont pas seulement inscrites sur des
missions spécifiques plan d'urgence ou
plan de relance mais elles sont
disséminées au sein de du budget par
ailleurs les crédits reportés ne sont
pas nécessairement pour ne pas dire
jamais consommé pour financer les
politiques publiques pour lesquelles ils
avaient été ouverts enfin rapporteur
spécial de la mission écologique je ne
peux pas ne pas évoquer la gestion
opportuniste des charges de services
publics de l'électricité ou encore le
changement de programme en cours
d'exécution des dispositifs de soutien à
la consommation de carburant les
montants en question ne sont pas
anecdotiques
par ailleurs les dispositifs visant à
atténuer pour les ménages le coût de la
hausse des prix des énergies ne
contribue absolument pas à atteindre les
objectifs environnementaux de la France
leur attachement à la mission écologique
et donc plus que contestable enfin et
pour conclure je relève que la démarche
de budget vert sur laquelle nous avons
émis déjà un certain nombre de réserves
méthodologiques s'arrête au milieu du
chemin en effet il n'y a pas de cotation
des
crédits réellement dépensés or ce sont
eux qui ont une action sur
l'environnement il faut donc poursuivre
le travail
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
Stéphane sotarel pour le groupe les
républicains pour 7 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
du budget mes chers collègues la loi de
règlement du budget et d'approbation des
comptes arrête le montant définitif des
recettes et des dépenses du budget
auquel elle se rapportent ainsi que le
solde budgétaire qui en découle pourtant
elle ne s'apparente pas aux simples
constats des comptes administratifs des
collectivités territoriales monsieur le
ministre sa portée est bien plus grande
il ne s'agit pas d'un simple constat ce
d'autant que le PLR 2022 ne tire aucun
enseignement des remarques faites lors
de l'examen du PLR 2021 ce PLR pour
l'année 2021 il a été rejeté par le
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale vient de
réexaminer il a été une nouvelle fois
rejeté par les députés et de même pour
le PLR 2022
en ce 3 juillet qui restera peut-être la
date de l'appel des mères plus que celle
du rejet des deux Chambres du PLR il
nous appartient donc de nous prononcer à
notre tour au Sénat sur l'un et l'autre
de ces textes contrairement au PLR 21
l'exercice budgétaire de 2022 et peu
marqué par la crise sanitaire néanmoins
la crise énergétique et l'inflation ont
encore contribué à l'augmentation des
dépenses de l'État sans qu'elle en soit
les seules responsables sans oublier
surtout que la dépense ordinaire n'a
cessé de croître on constate que le
solde le déficit va non structurel est
supérieur de 2,6 points en 2022 à la
prévision retenue dans la LPF
cela témoigne d'un état de nos finances
publiques particulièrement dégradé cela
pose aussi le problème majeur du
non-respect de l'autorisation
parlementaire dont vous faites peu de
cas pour la deuxième année consécutive
cela confirme l'urgence d'une nette
réduction du déficit structurel afin de
limiter le risque d'insoutenabilité de
la dette même si une croissance
exceptionnelle des recettes permet une
limitation du déficit du budget de
l'État et on peut s'en réjouir même si
cela risque de n'être que ponctuel
celui-ci est de l'ordre de 151,4
milliards d'euros soit une dégradation
de 58,8 milliards par rapport à 2019
avant la crise pandémique
cet effet recettes et je salue la baisse
du taux d'iesse qui s'accompagne d'un
accroissement de son rendement est
totalement gommé par une hausse continue
des dépenses plus 24% des dépenses
nettes du budget de l'État à nouveau
constant entre 2019 et 2022 pour
s'élever à 446 milliards d'euros les
dépenses des ministères sont quasiment
toutes en forte hausse les crédits de la
mission écologie ont par exemple plus
que doublé depuis 2020 16,7 milliards
d'euros en 2020 sans que cela ne finance
pourtant la nécessaire transition
écologique alors que le choc d'offre
notamment au niveau des mobilités dont
je suis rapporteur va demander des
moyens considérables nous n'avons
aujourd'hui amorcé aucun effort en la
matière la dépense ayant le plus
augmenté concerne les engagements
financiers de l'État qui intègre la
charge de la dette
qui a explosé un an avec une hausse de
13 milliards d'euros passant de 37,8 en
21 à 50,7 milliards en 22 alors qu'en
2017 l'écart entre recettes net et
dépenses nette était de 80,5 milliards
d'euros soit un écart de moins de 30%
entre les deux celui-ci est de
158,2 milliards d'euros en 2022 soit un
écart de plus de 55% entre les deux
lors des Assises des finances publiques
le 19 juin dernier vous avez annoncé 10
milliards d'économies elle semble encore
peu documentée mais surtout elles sont
particulièrement limitées la Cour des
comptes préconise au moins 60 milliards
d'euros de baisse de la dépense bref il
nous semble pas que nous soyons encore
sortis du quoiqu'il en coûte quand on
fait la somme des annonces du président
de la République à chacune de ces
sorties je me permets à ce stade un
aparté en qualité d'élus local pour vous
dire Monsieur le Ministre combien nous
avons mal vécu les 5,5 milliards d'euros
que le président veut consacrer à
Marseille en substitution à l'action
locale et qui contraste cruellement avec
les quelques millions d'euros annoncés
par la première ministre dans une
certaine indifférence d'ailleurs au
titre du nouvel agenda rural mais je
reviens au PLF
pardon sous évaluation fiscale report
massif de crédit en fin d'année au lieu
d'être annulé autorisation de programmes
non couverte constituant une dette sous
la ligne porte gravement atteinte au
principe d'endualité nuisent à la
lisibilité du budget et affaiblissent la
portée de l'autorisation parlementaire
même si la Cour des comptes a certifié
les comptes de l'État pour 2022 en
relevant toutefois quelques anomalies
surévaluation de certaines
participations sous évaluation d'autres
non mentions de l'engagement orbilant
par l'état de la garantie de la dette de
la BPI
le besoin de financement de l'État
s'établit à 280 milliards d'euros en
2022 s'il est inférieur de 17,6
milliards à celui projeté en LFI il
n'est pourtant plus soutenable
c'est là la principale faiblesse de nos
finances publiques le poids d'une dette
qui nous plombe et qui nous coûte de
plus en plus à cette heure son cou n'est
impacté que par l'effet de l'inflation
et pas encore par l'effet tôt qui ne va
pas manquer de nous frapper en 2024 la
dette va bientôt être le premier poste
de dépenses du budget de l'État le stock
de la dette publique vient de dépasser
les 3000 milliards d'euros à l'heure où
on parle et se situe désormais à plus de
112% du PIB cela ne semble plus effrayer
personne pourtant son coût inquiète déjà
12,9 milliards de plus de la charge de
notre dette en 2022 et tout cela
seulement pour dépenser au titre du
fonctionnement et pas pour préparer
l'avenir en investissant la Cour des
comptes il y a encore de rappeler ses
inquiétudes et de l'appeler à une
réduction plus conséquente de la dépense
je l'ai rappelé nous ne cessons de vous
proposer des réductions en s'attaquant
vraiment pour la dépense fiscale par
exemple au coût des agences aussi en
pratiquant une revue des dépenses
publiques exigeantes qui garantissent
les moyens des collectivités et recentre
ceux de l'État pour des raisons donc de
sincérité budgétaire de respect de
l'autorisation parlementaire pour des
raisons de situation très dégradées de
nos finances publiques qui ne font
l'objet d'aucune mesure sérieuse de
redressement le groupe LR ne votera pas
c'est de lois de règlement je vous
remercie si chers collègues la
discussion générale commune éclose nous
passons à la discussion des articles du
projet de loi rejeté par l'Assemblée
nationale de règlement du budget et
d'approbation des comptes de l'année
et à l'article liminaire un amendement
numéro 1 monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui vise à actualiser
l'article liminaire en effet depuis la
présentation au Conseil des ministres en
avril des deux projets de loi de
règlement l'Insee a le 31 mai dernier
actualiser les chiffres du PIB des
années 2020 en 2021 et 2022 si le
déficit public reste inchangé à moins
6,5% en 2021 et - 4,7% en 2022 le
partage entre soldes structurel et
soldes conjoncturel a été modifiée par
cette publication et donc mise à jour
dans cette amendement un autre
amendement fait la même chose sur le
projet de loi de règlement 2022
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
général des favorable je mets aux voix
l'amendement 1 du gouvernement avec un
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est rejeté je vois
l'article liminaire qui est pour
qui compte
qui s'abstient il est rejeté
je mets au voile article 2 même vote
pardon l'article premier va après avoir
l'article 2 quand même oui l'article
premier qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
merci les rejetés l'article 2 même vote
un
il est rejeté l'article 3 même vote
rejeter l'article 4 pareil
rejeté l'article 5
identique projeté vous en arrivez à
l'article 6 je vous rappelle que si cet
article n'était pas adopté il n'y aurait
plus lieu de voter sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi dans la mesure où tous les
articles composent ont été supprimés or
en application l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public est de droit sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de règlement
du budget en conséquence l'article 6 va
être mis aux voix par scrutin public
le scrutin public est ouvert
ça ne demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
343 exprimé 289 pour l'article 54 contre
235 les articles du projet de loi ont
été successivement supprimés par le
Sonnage constate qu'un vote sur
l'ensemble n'est pas nécessaire puisque
il n'y a plus de texte en conséquence ce
projet de loi est définitivement rejeté
et nous passons à la discussion des
articles du projet de loi cette fois-ci
pour 2022 à l'article liminaire un
amendement de Monsieur le Ministre
oui merci Monsieur président comme pour
le projet de loi de règlement 2021 c'est
un article qui ne fait qu'actualiser la
croissance constatée et la macroéconomie
constatée en 2022 par l'Insee dans sa
publication du 31 mai dernier
avis du rapporteur général
je mets aux voix l'amendement 2 du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission qui est pour
qui compte
qui s'abstient il est rejeté je mets au
voile article liminaire qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il est rejeté je mets au
voile article premier qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
rejeté pareil pour le 2
même vote pour le 2 même vote pour le 3
et à l'article 4 une prise de parole de
Monsieur la Mini
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre le président de la
commission sur le rapporteur général
chers collègues je m'étais engagé à nous
faire qu'une seule prise de parole donc
je le fais sur cet article 4 bons
concernant l'année 2022 règlement au
budget et des comptes
[Musique]
cela a été rappelé par les différents
orateurs
les dépenses sont on évoque au préalable
des articles précédents notamment le
besoin de financement les recettes alors
s'agissons des des dépenses par mission
il y a plus de 33 missions dans dans le
budget de de l'État et les crédits de
paiement s'élèvent à 578 milliards
d'euros pour 2022
pour mémoire en 2021 557 milliards
d'euros comme chiffre important à
retenir également moins 160 milliards
d'euros résultat comptable et les
produits fiscaux honnêtes 330 milliards
d'euros bon c'est vrai c'était aussi
largement rappelé l'anciennement
scolaire premier mission 78 milliards
d'euros les engagements financiers de
l'État 54 milliards l'achat dont la
charge de la dette la défense 51
milliards puis aussi après les autres
ministères qui sont aussi très
importants le volet collectivité
territorial et non on pourrait évoquer
aussi largement le problème d'autonomie
financière des collectivités
territoriales certes l'État reste le
premier partenaire de l'ensemble des
collectivités
territoriales alors
également les remboursements et des
rendements sont 32 milliards d'euros sur
ces dépenses moi je dirais je
m'absiendrai
sur sur cet article comme je ferai sur
le vote final puisque ça correspond au
compte administratif comme les
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie merci je vais donc mettre voix
l'article 4 alors sur le coup je refais
voter puisque il y a changement donc qui
est pour l'article 4
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est rejeté article 5 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est rejeté article 6 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est rejeté chers
collègues nous en arrivant à l'article 7
et même chose que tout à l'heure en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public et de droit sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de règlement
du budget d'approbation des comptes en
conséquence l'article 7 va être mis aux
voix parce scrutin public
le vote est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos
vos temps 343 exprimés 275 pour 41
contre 234 le projet de loi n'est pas
adopté
mais chers collègues je suspendre une
minute sur six pour permettre le
changement
de structure avant le prochain texte